dans la vie les découvertes mènent
généralement à de nouvelles questions
la seule variable constante est
l'inattendue on ne peut pas la contrôler
ce n'est que lorsque vous regardez en
arrière que vous voyez que tout était
lié nous pouvons commencer
c'est parfait j'aime cuisiner c'est de
la chimie
vous êtes sur le point de faire une
découverte scientifique majeure notre
institution a une réputation fondée sur
le travail de scientifiques de classe
mondiale elle ne se fonde pas sur les
théories d'une jolie laborantine ici
nous avons des règles vous me licenciez
[Musique]
j'aimerais vous proposer un travail
nouvelle animatrice de notre émission de
cuisine vous êtes tombés sur la tête non
vous êtes faite pour devenir une force
dans les programmes de l'après-midi
voici le souper est servi
il me faut une phrase d'accroche ne
réfléchis pas trop je ne sais pas du
tout ce que ça veut dire je défends
légèrement les bourreaux du travail de
la cuisine les femmes et les patates au
four
[Musique]
ce que tu dis à de l'importance la
politique n'a pas sa place dans une
cuisine un homme veut que sa femme lui
prépare à boire après une dure journée
de travail et pourquoi supposer que sa
journée à lui a été plus longue que la
sienne préparez-vous même ce cocktail
[Musique]
tu la personne que je serais le plus au
monde non pas pour ta beauté ni parce
que tu es intelligente mais parce que tu
m'aimes et que je t'aime
[Musique]
on y arrive quand même
notre capacité à changer tout ce qui est
démarre ici
[Applaudissements]
les enfants mettaient le couvert votre
mère a besoin d'un moment pour elle